walk him to this blitz game playing town
tavern from the UK no name okay that's
very bit with the kettle on check yeah
and I'm not in the mood for any game
birds and so get the porn back mmm how
do you play that actually not sure
and get it feels like to see fun it's
not a great place for my queen
should I take him I don't know maybe
Roxy one
or your phone efore CD for gap I cannot
book Queenie too because of Bishop c4
k so put put the Rukia it's not quite
clear what his next move is in what to
take so that he has gotten a media
temple yeah now i can i can take and
play Queen B 1 if I need to but maybe
here you fall you 45
come on keep it simple
it's probably not done anything great
but then didn't see how a really good
with the small be sure trilla play there
should be three yeah I guess exchanging
those cannot hurt
yeah it's not not to inspiring here to
one put it mildly looks like a mad at
best equal
yeah I have absolutely nothing if I can
just take not sure why why did I allow
that okay no this isn't isn't great as
well but he could have just taken
yeah really played that opening the less
than perfect how am NOT not even even
equal here
yeah not see for Queen a phone the Sun
is quite okay though k let's take it
slow cleaner phone yeah well yeah this
isn't too bad I mean it's not to grip my
I just blundering the pole great yeah
what's what nonsense I'm he can just
take it he can just take it
yeah okay I just I just didn't see that
at all
yeah gone down for nothing and I am two
minutes down yeah this was really crap
what the heck did I do that yeah the
only hope is some some rocket game which
you can in fact quite often draw from
from the earth positions
it's a double check
I don't know he's playing this song they
found more complicated fashion than
necessary but them for 24 seconds
24 seconds
hmm
so what are you doing now
hmm yeah 96 is not not even a real
threat
time warning yeah the time warning is a
rather late hey now I am I have a big
troll 2 to meet the time control
you
check check check check black forfeits
on time wow he was really slow and what
what what I what was happening here I
was I can take here yeah okay it was
just a matter of seconds against second
so check but I wanna ask can I went on
time after being so much down on time
but it was very slow ride yeah terrible
game what the heck did I do that
probably this opening was completely
rotten I mean Italy that should be equal
at least yeah if 45 is the comp booth
with baguette I thought about that but I
thought it wasn't working I couldn't
really figure out why this is good it
seems to be good ah ok and now I get it
I i saw this but i didn't see that move
and this is really great I of course now
I threatened to take him to the smooth
yeah I didn't see that and this is very
good now for white this is also not
helping so d5 and if he cannot take he's
in trouble because this here this esox a
d6 threatened so this is the the point
where I we're spoiled it
after this like is in excellent shape it
was was much better quickly yeah very
lucky game thanks for watching